welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz and with this episode it's a
slightly different one
and this is going to be part of the
entry-level stroke graduate
episode podcast series where we speak to
recruiters who are early on in their
recruitment journey
they may have graduated um and
they are sharing with us how it's going
what they've learned so far some of the
biggest challenges they've experienced
in hope that some of you listening to
this can either if you're considering a
cream recruitment can get a real picture
of what to expect and some practical
advice
and also if you are early on in your
recruitment career
to know that you're not what you're
going through you're not going for it
alone
and also to hear how other people are uh
making the most of their recruitment
career so far so
i'm really uh excited to be joined by
hannah and rachel from finley james and
before
we get into this hannah if you could
introduce yourself
and make sure you do the same and then
we'll um get into it
yeah sure so hi everyone my name's
hannah as mentioned
so i joined finley james back in march
2020 so coming up to like a year and a
half now
and we specialize in placing people in
the tech and software space
and primarily like sales and leaders as
well as
marketing professionals i typically
specialize in
the ed tech and learning tech space as
well
amazing love that so you've been you've
recruited a year and a half and did you
did you graduate did you go to
university yes so i went to mammot
university
graduated two years ago now and did a
textiles degree
awesome and rachel yeah
so my name's rachel i also work at
philly james
and i've been doing recruitment for
around about 10 months now so i think i
joined in
august 2020 um
and i also obviously specialize in the
tech space
and my um kind of where i like to
work on is the martech space i really
like
any marketing technology um and data
analytics space as well
awesome and then for context of 10
months and then did you graduate last
year
i graduated two years ago as well i had
a previous sales job for
this okay awesome so where i want to
start then rachel i'll come to you first
yeah obviously you had a sales job
before but like
how and why did you end up choosing to
get into recruitment after that sales
job let's just let's just stop there
yeah so i i'm originally from swansea i
don't even tell them
but um i wanted to move to manchester
just because there's so many more
opportunities up here and i think it's a
really cool city
and so i was trying to look for jobs up
here and i did enjoy my sales job but i
didn't really i was kind of open to any
job because i've obviously
only graduated a year before that i was
quite open and then i saw
a job online through recruitment agency
but
it was just um i think it was another
sales job
and then they rang me up and they kind
of pre-screened me and
um they were actually like oh have you
ever been into job and recruitment am i
like no
not really and they were like oh you
think you'd be really good at it would
you would you want to go to some uh
recruitment interviews and i was like
yeah i was open for anything so i was
like yeah go on
and then the first one i did was
actually with vinnie james
um and like the minute i went into the
office i just
absolutely loved it it's such a cool
office everyone in that was so nice and
i really enjoyed the interview process
so
i kind of just fell into it that way
just by kind of coincidence wasn't i
actually thought
about you know i wanted a career in
recruitment it's just kind of came to me
okay interesting and um hannah just
muted you there because it
it's a bit of a bad noise so i just knew
when rachel's talking but
what about your story then um no sorry
hannah sorry not rachel
um what what was your story into
recruitment and hannah how
how did it unravel for you not too far
off to be honest with reaches so
graduated from uni i did a really
creative course
and i was really torn like where i
wanted to to go down whether that was
pursuing more about the art style room
or just going into something completely
different so when i was doing some art
commission work and stuff like that
on the side i picked up a door-to-door
um
sales job wow that that i actually
weirdly really enjoyed was what was you
selling
uh well it was actually bernardo's for
the children's charity
oh wow okay sign up to the charity so i
did feel like i was doing something good
but um i realized i actually just really
thrived off getting to speak to new
people every day
and my dad was like hang on you're
actually really good at this why are you
doing this and standing outside in the
rain every day when you could be doing a
sales job inside
um and i was like yeah i know but i've
got no idea about
sales or anything like that and he's the
one that suggested recruitment because
he has some
um some friends and family and
recruitment and stuff and was like have
you ever thought about it and
same thing as rach i just started
applying i really had no clue
what i even meant but i just i knew it
was a sales job and i knew that i just
wanted to
move out the creative space and just
push myself to do something new
um so yeah same thing with rach just
sort of fell into
it fell into recruitment interviewed at
philly james and was like i really love
love this company and joined i love that
so back to
you then hannah real quick so i have to
ask
like i feel like this is something that
we all have to work through in our lives
but i feel like it's even more
intensified especially when
you've gone to uni obviously taking on
all of that debt that's part of that
journey as well so like
i guess any advice for people listening
that may be graduating this year or
recently graduating they still
have no idea what the hell they want to
do
like what helps you i don't know like
what comes up for you when if i'm sent
to you
look at him i'm just really worried at
the moment i don't know what i want to
do
i'm like all these sorts of things like
how did you deal with those feelings and
did you experience those
yeah 100 and i think for me
it's important to try as much as
possible not to compare yourself to
everyone else because i was watching all
my friends getting
design jobs straight away or people
landing like the dream job in like
teaching or whatever it was straight
away and i was just out there thinking
i have literally got nothing i've got no
idea what i'm doing my life oh my god
i'm a failure
but it's just you have to step back and
realize we're still so young there's so
much time
even people in like the 40s and 50s
still don't even know
what they want to do and so they just
take a step back
enjoy your time off when you've got some
um and then just try and go out there
and explore
as many options as possible and
interview as many places and then
it'll probably click and you'll probably
find something you think actually
this might not be what i thought i'd be
good at or i wanted to do but this is
what feels right and just go with
go with the flow i love that and then
rachel back to you then what was your
experience with that and those
those feelings yeah so i had a similar
experience i
a lot of my friends are medics so they
had their career path
kind of set out for them they didn't oh
wow do
um obviously they've never done
interviews really because they've got a
set plan they've been in uni for the
last five years
so i felt like similar i was very
stressed because i i just didn't know
what i wanted to do and i think it's
quite an uncertain feeling when you
graduate
you think you've you've got you've like
said you're in the load of that you've
gone to get a degree to get a really
good job but like
it's so hard to find what you're looking
for if you don't know what you want to
do you can't even look for jobs online
because
it's like it's so overwhelming you're
like i don't know what to choose don't
know what i'm
good at but yeah my advice would be you
know take some time have a look at some
just
any job go for some interviews and see
get a feel for kind of what you like
if you think the culture's nice if you
like the people there and when they talk
about the job if you can see yourself
doing it because
sometimes the job description as we were
saying does put people off but
i from the job description that i've
seen on recruitment is nothing like what
i actually thought
i would be doing so i was under the
impression that you know you you fly
over
job ads out and then you wait for people
to come back to you and then you just
bring people that and it's like
completely different
from that like it's not like that at all
so i think yeah if you if you try and
it kind of go to as many jobs as you can
and
don't worry about it i spent like a few
weeks on
trying to enjoy my time off but i
couldn't because i was just panicking
thinking i'm never gonna get a job
and i was just trying to like get any
job that i possibly could which is not
necessarily equally the right thing to
do because you might you know get into a
job that you really really don't like
and just take them for the sake of it
and so yeah i think just take a step
back
find to try and find what you think you
would enjoy like what are you what do
you enjoy in life and see if there's any
you know job avenues down from that
yeah nice yeah i think it's just
experimenting isn't it like
and like being open to that i think a
lot obviously we put a lot of pressure
pressures on ourselves to like have
the perfect career or find it perfectly
and actually i think i just don't like
the time as well i know
obviously i always use set to of
candidates and i'm sure you've had some
of these conversations as well like job
hoppy
and you don't want too many jobs in your
cv and stuff but when you're younger
like [ __ ] out yeah like you're just
trying to find out who you are
and make your way in this world it's
like to go oh i'm not going to do that
because that's going to affect my cv
it's like well no
you need to experience you need to try
different things and the only like and
then not worry about that and
yeah so like i feel like people are
going to be more and more understanding
of that in today's
society as well if like rachel had five
jobs in
three years compared to someone that had
two jobs well actually you're actually
more rounded or you have
a more different experience and now you
may have a better understanding of what
you're doing right or
what you want to do so i guess back to
you
then rachel um like what skill so
obviously you both fell into it but like
what skills or experience then has
recruitment given you that you least
expected
yeah so like multitasking i've got to
say that's one of the biggest ones
because i think
again you're under the impression that
you're kind of doing one thing day after
day but it's
like there's so many different aspects
you've got like the client side of
things where you're speaking with
clients trying to bring on new business
we've also got to reach out to
candidates you know that are not
actively looking for jobs you've got to
kind of try to
you know persuade them into maybe start
looking for a job when they weren't
ready to look and then you've also got a
kind of manage
i don't know if there's like for other
recruitment companies but we at finney
james work in a really collaborative
environment so
because we are quite new to recruitment
um we are obviously working
other people's jobs in they've brought
on so you've got to work together to
kind of get the deal over the line
so that's with the client that's with
also the people at finley james your
colleagues
you know and the candidate so it's a lot
of stuff
that you've got to kind of juggle all in
one you've got to do practicals
it's just so much and i think you've got
to really really work on your time
management because
if you don't have like a good set plan
for the day it's so easy to get down
like a rabbit hole and
not actually get done anywhere near as
much as you think you would um
so those are the two things for me time
management and
multitasking yeah nice and then hannah
i'll ask you the same question in a
second about just
before i do what about like personally
as well because
for me personally when i got into sales
and stuff like i really found i don't
know i just feel like
it did make me more confident in
speaking to people and i don't know i
just feel like it gave me more
than just like the professional stuff
like anything do you feel like it's
helped you even like as rachel the human
being the person you think has impacted
anything out of interest
working in recruitment
yeah definitely i think like also
because you have to speak to the clients
on
on a daily basis as well like when i
first joined i've never even spoken to
someone like really high up in a
business or
you know i was just in uni had no kind
of obviously i was like working in a
coffee shop for most of them
but that's like nothing compared to like
speaking to you know
see we're speaking to ceos most of the
time and like that can be quite daunting
um but you know after you face a second
go you really find your groove and
like i find my confidence improved like
not just in the workplace but
you know when you're going out and
meeting new people um
i just feel like i'm such a more
confident person now
like i feel like i could you know walk
before i was like even shy it's like all
the stuff
oh wow like that but now i literally am
like a whole new person so yeah i think
it really has improved my confidence
like
in work and outside work love that
so then um hannah over to you the same
question really like
what skills and things does it sort of
have you obtained you think so far that
you least expected yeah so i'd
definitely say
a bit of an obvious one like rachel as
well but the time management but more
like down to like being self-disciplined
so i think it's like when i first went
into this
it was i was spending hours on one thing
and then being like oh my god
i've not got anything on my to-do list
done today but it's just having that
like self-discipline to be like no stop
and move on now and just being able to
get on and move on with your day
if maybe things take a little bit longer
but then it's fine um as long as you've
got what you need to do just move on
um and then i think for me it's actually
patience
so job where you can't
like you really do have to be patient
with people people are very
unpredictable
um and i think going into this i just
thought everything would go as
planned everyone would do as you'd say
um
but it's a complete opposite so again
just yeah having a little bit patience
sometimes a deal could drop in like
three months later than you thought it
would take
there's long notice periods involved
like all of that stuff
it's not a quick thing so it's just been
able to go with the flow of the process
and just have a little bit more patience
with everything and which is good that's
patience
self-discipline and then this is a bit
of an odd one actually but i think as
well
um because i've been speaking to people
probably more so than anywhere in the us
and then even like in europe's likes of
germany and things it's just having that
cultural awareness as well so literally
never spoke
when i got told you're working on a u.s
role as thinking i've never spoken to
someone
in the us in my entire life
what they're gonna be like but now like
i know how to speak to them i suppose
you know maybe someone
over in germany and just building up
rapport but in different ways versus
like the cultures in the country
and that sort of thing and so that's
quite an interesting one
i love that and i think that's just one
of the greatest things about recruitment
i think like how
like communication skill having good
communication skills in life is just
so valuable and it can help you in like
all areas so
so we've been we've kept it like quite
positive i feel like so
i guess hand it back to you then like
what what have been your biggest
challenges so far then
to like because we all here and i
definitely experience this like
first gen recruitment is horrible might
even be the worst year of your life or
most difficult
i don't know how difficult uni was and
stuff like that but like first year in
recruitment it's going to be difficult
so like what have been some of the
biggest challenges that you've had to
face
and then i guess how even you still may
be working through them but
i guess then what comes up for you when
how you sort of gone about overcoming
them or dealing with them
what comes up for you on that yeah so i
think for me
it's probably coming down to like lack
of confidence in myself
or like sort of imposter syndrome um so
when i joined in march 2020 that was
literally i had two weeks of training
and then
we were suddenly in lockdown i was sat
there thinking oh my god my job is
it's definitely not safe i'm gonna have
to leave and find a new job
um so from the start i was just
panicking but to be fair
philly james was so supportive we had a
lot of sort of weekly catch ups over
zoom
keeping everyone in the business up to
date with where we stand as a business
in terms of like the revenue
in terms of the plans but also i was
made to feel like your job is safe we
are going to get you through this
obviously you're going to have to work
hard
but throughout i was just thinking how
have i kept this job i don't deserve to
be here
i've literally had no experience so i
think over furlough i was just
consistently
trying to improve and learn as much as
possible i was watching your podcasts um
books and that sort of thing so when i
came in i was like right i've learned as
much as i can now and i'm gonna go in
and smash it but i think
throughout the whole process even coming
back in it's just constantly having to
remind yourself like
i'm not perfect but i can do this and
i'm always just
having to like battle in my own head
like you can do this
like you deserve to be here you've
worked really hard and so i think it's
just
recognizing when you hear that voice in
your head and
it's so natural to like go into it and
be like yeah like i'm doing it awfully
but it's switching it and recognizing
that you're doing it and just trying to
be like
no stop a minute i'm doing all i can
i've done really well so far
and just thinking more rationally about
it i love that yeah so just
getting better at recognizing the self
dialogue and noticing if it's
serving you or isn't serving you and
trying to change yeah i love that
and then rachel same question for you
then really
like what what have been some obviously
you're still obviously coming up to that
uh year mark which is exciting so like
what
what have been obviously still here
still still
still in the job surviving doing it
making it happen like what
what have been some of your biggest
challenges so far then you've had to to
work through do you think
yeah well i always had a bit of a rocky
start so i actually got off of the job
in march
and i was so excited to start handed him
my notice and then
obviously the pandemic hit so i was
absolutely gutted because obviously i
was like really excited i was like
there's no way they're gonna keep i also
thought there's no way they're gonna let
me start
and then um obviously they let me know
obviously i wasn't going to start but
they were like don't worry you know we
do really want you to start we just
don't know what and
so i was like every month for getting in
touch like do you still want me to do so
hungry
and like they were so good like every
month like yes we promised like as soon
as we get a solid start date and we know
you know you will be starting they were
so informative and you know
really because it was quite
nerve-wracking because i couldn't go on
furlough because i'd
already handed in my notice and i
obviously couldn't go on further from
philly james either so it was quite a
nerve-wracking
um position to be in because i wasn't
sure if any other
people would be taking on jobs either
but they were amazing in keeping me
informed
and then i started in august and i had a
great few months and i think i really
really wanted to prove myself because i
was like i really want to keep this job
so i ended up becoming the fastest
person to ever be promoted
so a massive high and then um
since we've kind of come out of the
pandemic um
one of the things i've really struggled
with is because i've only known a
covered market i started
during covert where there was not that
many jobs but whereas now we've gone
like the other extreme where there's too
many jobs so there's so many counter
offers half
counter offers happening you know you've
got a speech candidate through the
process
otherwise you know they're getting
snapped up really quickly and i think
the thing that i've you know struggled
with
especially in the last like two months
is is dealing with those overcoming
trying to make sure that my candidates
you know are
you know getting spread through the
process or
adapting to this sort of environment i
think that's one of the challenges that
i've faced and like obviously going from
such a high to then now
obviously i'm trying to adapt to this
new market
um that's been you know a big big
challenge for me
um so i'm just hoping i kind of
see the other end now and go back right
back up well yeah well a lot a lot of um
i'm sure you might have heard john say
this but a lot of people say if you
if you can make it happen in a market
like clover then you you
there's a very good chance you'll make
it in a stronger market but you're right
it's different challenges right and
having to adapt and things like that so
i guess um
what i wanted to obviously uh ask you
both then so rachel on this then so
this is something that came up when i
was speaking to um
a couple of people so obviously both of
you said that
it sort of happened quite quite by
accident getting into recruitment right
so
hopefully you'd agree but fair to say
that there may not have been like a
really solid
why you wanting to get into recruitment
at the beginning but disagree me if you
want to
but i guess what i wanted to ask you is
in those sort of early
early periods what can be really hard to
sort of i guess really tap into is
like why you're doing it and that
motivation so i guess my question
for both of you and rachel to you first
like how well she had that highest
obviously i feel like
the financial stuff that helps with
motivation but then when you've had
challenges like what what have you
tapped into like to be more mo to be
motivated to carry on and like what's
helped you understand
like why why you're now in recruitment
and what does that make sense like
because
that's really hard to be at the
beginning yeah i think
um a big thing for me is when i am
struggling i feel like i've got
really good clothes like although my
colleagues are also
you know my friends because as i said i
moved up from swansea i only knew my
boyfriend here i didn't really have
anyone else so
um i only know the people like my
colleagues and they're now
you know really close friends of mine
and one thing that really helped me
through you know if you ask juggman
is just talking about it with people who
understand like i come home sometimes
and i'll try and speak to my boyfriend
about it he just doesn't get
it he's like it's like what are you on
about but like having
like that you can vent to you know
people that fully understand i found
that really helps you they can help
motivate you you know if you are
struggling that day you know they'll be
like no come on you've got this
i also found listening to motivational
podcasts as well and
i love podcasts myself um so i listen to
you know if i'm having a
like a little bit of a down day like
sometimes i will listen to like a
motivational podcast and it'll really
like get me in the mood
um but i think since i've started
recruitment and
like hence why i want to stay is you
know
i do love the buzz of of of closing that
deal like that that
is although the lows are low the highs
are really high and everyone says that
and
it is so it's such a satisfying feeling
you know when you do get a placement and
you you know you've crossed over the
line it may have taken like you said a
month or two months but you've done it
and also you know the people like i said
the people you work with like i
i love everyone that i work with and i
find it's so much fun walking into the
office and seeing everyone i think
that's the you know
a big big reason why like recruitment is
so fun especially at finn and james
just because the the collabs environment
is just so nice
nice i love that and then i guess same
for you then
hannah like what have you what's helped
you tap into your motivation and how
have you
remained motivated in this sort of early
part of your career
yeah so i think um for me in the morning
like before i start work i always do
something whether like writing in a
journal or
speaking to myself in the mirror and
just reminding like why i'm doing it um
but i'm quite a big book reader as well
um so yeah just reading
um books all the time or like rachel's
always listening to podcasts whatever it
is on the drive to work just something
to get you quite pumped up
and then it's just reminded myself why
it started and i think with recruitment
obviously like rache said you're gonna
have
you could have a tough day tough week
even like a tough month
but it's looking at the bigger picture
um and
sort of the life skills that you
actually are developing along the way
from this
is really invaluable like it's testing
you and it's really
a job where you're getting used to being
in the uncomfortable zone
um but i think that's where you're gonna
be successful in the long run
so it's reminding yourself that um and
then another thing
is definitely because every day is
different so i'm probably someone that
gets quite
bored um doing the same thing every day
you know like a set routine i just get a
bit irritable so
knowing that every day you literally
have no idea what to expect and
i do think the time goes by so fast
which is always a plus
um and then like rachel again it's the
people at finley james as well like
we've we've all become so close and
we've all obviously gone through cobid
and we know
it's just been a tough year but i think
we've all just bonded a lot over that
and we've got like a really good
um collaborative team at finley james
and i genuinely think everyone else is
everyone there is just so supportive of
each other so it's just such a good
feeling to know you're never alone which
is
it's always a plus i love that so
as we um come to the last sort of 10
minutes of this so like what i guess
let's now think about so for you hannah
like going
obviously the journey you've been on so
far so for anyone listening that
may have recently graduated or it's sort
of a point in their life where they are
considering a career change
but maybe we could keep it specific to
um
grads because that's um obviously part
of your journey like what
what advice do you have for them then if
they're entering
like work for the first time this year
they may have done obviously your job
during uni but like what advice would
you give them do you think
i think go in there and you need to
remember you're not going as
in as a pro you're not an expert in this
job
but i think the number one thing to show
is is the attitude
so it's that willingness to to learn
really in that
sort of positive mindset and don't be
afraid to
ask questions because i remember when i
first started i was that person that was
asking about
50 questions a day and i was just
thinking i'm so annoying i can't believe
how many questions
i'm asking but i actually think that's
part of the reason i was kept on
throughout kobe because i was showing
that willingness to
you know to learn and try and find out
as much about the job as possible
and so yeah it's for me number one is
the attitude and the willingness to
learn
um and just don't be afraid like just go
with the flow with it and don't put too
much pressure on yourself at the same
time and obviously
make sure you're still taking care of
your mental health
so you're not spiraling and and you're
not um you know leaving some time for
yourself and self-care and stuff like
that
that's brilliant and then the the
follow-up to that then is like how
and then rachel asked the same thing
from what you think but like
how do you think then what would your
advice be for people that want to stand
out so like if i'm if i i'm graduating
this year
i know there's gonna be loads of other
people graduating i'm applying for jobs
like i said there's a lot of jobs a lot
of opportunities but there's also gonna
be a lot of competition
potentially like what would your advice
be for me to try and stand out amongst
other graduates or entry-level talent do
you think yeah so
funny but my boyfriend's actually just
graduated from uni this year
and he's been applying to jobs and just
updating the cv and he's like han why is
no one coming back to me
and i was like right you need to be
doing something different so
if there's a number or you go and you
need to find someone's number and you
need to be ringing them and standing out
or whether that's you know getting on
linkedin and getting
on social media and posting videos or
just thinking outside the box how you
can be um
approaching people to make yourself
stand out so getting cvs from left right
and center
so whether that's like you do a
personalized video
email to the the hiring manager or
whatever it is
just try and think of ways to to gain
some attraction that's not just sending
cvs through to every
um job application possible yeah nice
love that
and then i guess um rachel anything to
add to that that you think could
help people stand out do you think
yeah i also obviously completely agree
with what hannah said but obviously when
you get the chance
i think when you do get an interview is
really like your personality come across
i think a lot of people
when they do go to interviews it is
quite daunting when you've just
graduated and you know you haven't had
much into
experience and it does take a while to
kind of get into you know the groove and
you've got to get in like interview mode
as such
like you know you know what the client's
looking for you know what sort of
questions are kind of come up
but i think like to make yourself stand
out you do have to kind of really let
your personality shine through and don't
be
you know so try and not get in your head
and be a little bit rigid because i
think
obviously from my experience when i was
interviewing for a little like it took
me a while to kind of fully relax
in the interviews and i was like coming
across probably like a
like a plank of wood like really stiff
like not really like
like remembering my answers and like
saying them words for words
remembering them and i know it sounds
really stupid but i think a lot of
people when you graduate you you do you
get a list prepared and you kind of get
all your answers right but i think
i know it's cliche but just be yourself
try and black try and enjoy yourself
um whilst you're in it nice but also
obviously yeah and we've got a new
starter that you know
really stepped out of his comfort zone
and actually like stood at london and
had a sign
like saying i'm looking for new jobs
which is obviously
yeah i saw that way of of you know
finding a new job so yeah if you try and
come up with any other way than just
sending a cv
because your cv is gonna probably be
like just
under a load of other piles of paper
so you've got to try and make sure that
you've got to keep reminding them maybe
if you did send it like last week maybe
you want to ring them keep chasing them
and just make sure that you know that
they know who you are
yeah love that so i've got two final
questions for you both so
rachel um coming to you first and so no
this is something that you both
wanted to talk about so um women in
recruitment
yeah obviously obviously recruitment as
a whole typically has
the image of a male dominated industry
right
so i guess i know when you spoke about
this is something that
um you found out or thought about so i
guess obviously the question really is
um how have you had like how have you
found being in an environment where
there um are uh more men and males
and what what has that been like um and
i guess really like how
did you go about navigating that
environment or i don't know any
one i guess you could talk about it in
the sense of
like if i am a bit worried about that
what to think about or what you would
say to them
um if that makes sense yeah
well i think i didn't when i when i
walked into finney james
half we have 50 50 i think we've
actually got more females than males
and so i didn't even notice it kind of
coming in i didn't think
oh my gosh i'm going into a room full of
males when i was interviewing i think if
i had done that that would have been
i think that probably would have put me
off which
which you shouldn't do like in the
future but i think yeah
going in as a graduate going into an
interview place with a load of
um males i think that that daphne would
have put me off
um but why would it put you off
i think it's just very intimidating and
i also think uh
it makes you guess in your head maybe
you know women can't do the job which is
an awful thing to say but you think you
know if you've got
why is there a reason why why is there
anything else
you know you you don't really want to
think about like maybe yeah it just gets
in your head that you don't think that
you can do the job i think i would walk
in and be like oh that is a male
dominated industry
um but since being at philly james
obviously most of our top performers are
females which is obviously
amazing yeah um so yeah we've got a
really good gender split
but i think um what's important is to to
not
have the mindset that i had and like
walk in and think just because you are
the only girl that you can't do the job
like if anything you want to go in and
try and show that you can do it better
than than everyone that's already there
um so i think just like not letting
gender bias put you off
try and be that person that kind of
disrupt that gender by us
um because you know women have been so
successful in recruitment it's not to
say that we can't
do the job so you know don't be afraid
and kind of push yourself out of your
comfort zone even if you think that
you know you shouldn't be doing it it's
really important i think to just
just get in and try and do your best
love that
and i guess hannah anything to add to
that from your own experiences
yeah i think even just to start off with
other no
rage touched upon this earlier but it's
like even when you're applying
to jobs as a girl um i found out things
like the job descriptions
are quite like male heavy wording so the
things like competitive
and i think we need to be using more
female terminology as well because
the job can be done very well by females
there's a lot of
things like skills like emotional
intelligence empathy
like listening skills that females do
really really well at not to say that
men can't but
you know we can as well and they need to
be actually used in
the job descriptions because i think
they're just completely off-putting to
even start with
and now we've got this idea behind you
know sales is a really male heavy
you know like wall street type
environment when it doesn't need to be
and it's in
philly james it's not like that at all
and i think when i walked into philly
jones i was so shocked at
how different it was to what i thought
it could be
and i know obviously not all places are
going to be like that but it's just
don't be afraid and just go in there and
prove yourself and
as females in the tech space if we're
doing well
we need to be you know putting that out
there and showing other people and
and other female graduates that it can
be done
um and that we can be successful in it
as well
yeah i love that so final question then
um
for you hannah is how like why do we
think then
people should consider recruitment as a
career
rather than it being typically an
accident like why what would you say to
like why should it
why should people consider it do you
think so
definitely it's just going to improve
your life skills and i
like i look at myself back in march and
like i feel like a completely different
now so
that's 100 something if you're looking
to grow um
i think also if you're quite monument
motivated quite an obvious one
but if you go in there and you do apply
yourself and you learn as much as
possible it really is a type of job
where
you could genuinely uh you know get
promoted soon like rach mentioned she
was a faster to be promoted
i'm on track to get promoted very soon
and i've got like i'm
exceeding my targets and it's such a
lovely feeling to know that
you're doing well and it's definitely
the type of job that you actually get
that sense of achievement
and you actually feel like you're going
somewhere um
and it's even like a type of role that
you could move into you know like a
management position or whatever it is in
the future it's not just you're gonna
stay in this role forever there's a lot
of scope
and a lot of valuable life skills that
you're gonna learn so i think anyone
considering it it's
genuinely like a really good long-term
job and not just something that you're
gonna do just for six months
and then leave absolutely love that
thank you and then rachel same question
how why should people be considering
recruitment as a career not just
an accident yeah as hannah said i think
if you're looking for a job you know
which has high rewards you know
you if you work really hard there's
opportunity in a huge amount of money
and i don't think people realize i think
that people think yeah you can make
money there is opportunity
to earn a lot of money you know if you
are doing really well
and also you know with with more money
becomes
you know more progression and also you
can move up to a management
position really quickly probably more so
than you would in any other job
then also opens doors to if you did want
to maybe eventually become a manager
elsewhere you know you can go down a
different route you know
you really gain experiences that you can
take and and hopefully
um progress more later down the line
um but i also think that you know the
incentives like not a lot of companies
do
really fun cool incentives you know
we've got um
weekly lunch clubs quality lunch clubs
you also have got the incentive to go to
new york at the end of this year you
know if you hit your target
like there's really big motivators that
come along you know
sometimes the job is hard but also you
know there's loads of things that make
up for that
and i think that also contributes to
having such a fun working environment
because you're all you know
um working to get onto these incentives
and you want to get on you want to make
sure that your friends get on them so
you're encouraging your friends to get
on them as well if you don't want to go
to the lunch club by yourself you're
like come on
so i think it's just a lot more fun
rather than just work work work
um so yeah that would be my advice if
you do want to start
i love that so i know i said that's
gonna be my last question but sorry i'm
gonna ask you one more
and then it'll be our last one i promise
so back to you rachel so i just think
this is an interesting one so
um a lot of recruitment businesses will
want to hire
amazing people like both of you right
they want to hire
graduates who want to hire entry level
talent train them up and make them the
sort of next
highest performers in in their um
business right so
but obviously a lot of the time
obviously these business owners are
a lot older than both of you right so
the question is
like what what do what do what do um
what are the actual types of businesses
that you want to work for like what
what are the actual benefits that
actually like talk to you
do you know what i mean i feel like
because i feel like the typical one's
just always like you can learn all this
cash
obviously i know they said the
incentives and stuff but just out of
interest like for you rachel first like
what
what what types of actual recruitment
businesses
like do people like you actually want to
work for like what are you actually
motivated by what actually
captures your eye or speaks to you and
what actual types of benefits also speak
to you as a
young person building out their career
yeah i think one for me is having people
similar age
i think a lot of a lot of my friends are
kind of jealous that i've started and
i've got like me and hannah are both the
same age
like quite a few of us are the same age
we've got like a nice
group you know all graduate at the same
time and i feel like that is
that is quite important i think to have
people of a similar age group to you you
know that that makes things a lot more
fun
and you've got like quite a lot in
common as well um
but also like you said some a company
that's constantly changing and updating
i think it's important to kind of
keep with the times you know you don't
want to work for a company that's still
using like a database from 30 years ago
like it's important i think to kind of
keep up to date you know with
a new technology especially because
you're in the tech space
i think companies that can consistently
evolved and also adapt so
like i like working with clients at the
moment that have realized that
um obviously candidates are getting
stamped up quickly so they've
reduced their um interview stages
because they realize they can't be doing
a six stage process anymore because it's
just not they're not going to get
but then some clients you know are
sticking to their ways like no i'm still
gonna
do six days process and then end up not
getting the candidate that they want so
i think it's important to kind of
you know keep up to date notice what's
going on around you and continually
improving and also big thing for me is
listening to
um your employees so i like the fact
that
we have um weekly not weekly like
monthly feedback so one team
one member of each team member will go
and speak to managers and say
what we think we can improve on what
what kind of
we didn't enjoy this month what might be
good going forward and then we do
implement them straight away so they'll
happen the week after we'll try to test
out and see if it's going to improve
i think that really really is important
for me as well
um to make sure that employers are here
just fast in this day and age
yeah nice love that and then yeah final
question to you hannah like what
what actually speaks to young people
like what actually gets them excited
about a business
i think it's just working for a company
that actually cares about you
like you're not just another so again
the whole thing with the diversity
like you actually feel worthy of being
in the job um
they're big advocates of things like
mental health and so we've got people at
philly james
regularly checking in like how are you
doing um
and there's that flexible um working
where you've actually got
trust in your employees to do the job
and it's not you know you have to work
now
till then stupid like late hours there's
no pressure to work long hours it's just
as long as you get the you know what you
need to be done that's absolutely fine
and you need to take care of your mental
health
and you need time for yourself um
because i've heard these horror stories
of some other recruitment companies you
know like you need to be working till
like 10 at night you're not having a
break
until you've done 50 calls of whatever
it is and i just think that's a really
toxic sort of environment to work in so
yeah i think number one is trusting in
your people supporting your people
and making you actually feel like you
deserve to be there
um i'm pushing on the whole yeah
diversity piece as well
you know it's not just a 99 male
company and they're big on supporting
females in the tech space as well
love that hannah rachel has been an
absolute pleasure
excited to see how your recruitment
career continues
and uh thanks for joining me thank you
so much